foreign
today was to point out a dichotomy that
I think underlies much of what we are
now seeing
including the uh
loss of people like Sam and Claire from
this discussion
um what I think they would say about why
they've left is that they've been
hounded by people and if you look on
Twitter you will see that the
conventional wisdom about what is true
with respect to things on which they've
both taken very strong positions
has shifted radically and so what I
wanted to talk about is
now that we are almost three years into
the covid phase of History
I want to talk about what happened with
respect to
um
people's intellectual standing and
people's intellectual performance that
there's an interesting pattern that I
think comes down to a single dichotomy
about which we can say a lot of nuanced
things but a single dichotomy that
separates those who ended up uh
severely damaging their reputations
and those who in the end turned out to
be right in spite of what may have been
said about them before now obviously I
believe you and I are in that latter
category where it is increasingly clear
that um our concerns about the vaccines
or if anything over cautious that uh our
skepticism of their utility was well
placed
that our belief that there are
alternatives that might well have been
applied that weren't being used because
they weren't profitable seems to be
accurate and our argument that this does
not appeal appear to be a natural
pandemic but in fact Downstream of a lab
leak that is in fact linked to some of
the same people who have given us such
bad policy with respect to treating and
controlling the disease that that also
turns out to be well supported by the
evidence so
how the heck did we do it right and why
did so many others fail to including Sam
and Claire
and the point I want to make is that I
think there are really
two approaches to
um clear thinking
and it comes down to
that's really cute what uh
does one
attempt as is now taught in graduate
school in effectively every field as far
as I can tell does one attempt to figure
out which model is best and then become
expert in applying it
or does one deploy a model and compare
its results to the emerging evidence and
adjust the model accordingly and move in
the direction of better and better
models right and my claim is going to be
that our entire expert class was doing
the former thing
it was practiced at a game in which it
would identify a model that was claimed
to be the best maybe it was maybe it
wasn't but such a model and then it
applied that model it applied it with
great Nuance sometimes but it applied
that model and it doubled down on it and
at the point that model turns out to be
false they go down with the ship and
that happened in the space of a very
short time span with respect to covet
and often shouting about how they the
ship can't possibly be going down
because uh they were promised they were
assured they looked into it themselves
the model is right the model must be
right and that is the Curious thing
about this is if you check in with these
people
you do not get what I would ordinarily
expect of intellectuals which is at
least grudging acknowledgment that they
had taken a position that turned out not
to be right and maybe I would expect
amongst the lower quality ones excuse
making about how they got suckered by
some piece of evidence that mesmerized
them when they should have been looking
at something else but instead what you
find is a kind of insistence that no in
fact they were right and
they still are and so that is going to
be the red flag if your position on Cove
it hasn't changed radically then your
position isn't your position it's
something else right it's you deploying
a position held by something else and so
anyway what I'm going to argue yeah go
ahead there's
appears to me
um
in science in the kinds of science that
we were trained in and and engaged in in
many rooms under many circumstances and
in many forests under many circumstances
uh we were assured that you don't prove
a hypothesis correct
um that this was you know the
falsificationist uh kind of of science
sort of paparian thinking in which uh
you can
work very very hard uh to try to falsify
an idea a hypothesis and if you fail to
do that if you fail to falsify a
cherished or not cherished hypothesis
after a lot of hard work you have
greater and greater confidence that it
is true but you don't ever completely
know that it is true and so one of the
things that I hear you saying here is
um and we talked a couple weeks ago and
I wrote actually a couple weeks ago in
actual sections about the nature of
certainty that you know do do are you
comfortable with
an idea oh other people who I am
supposed to trust or I do trust say that
thing is correct therefore that's it one
hypothesis one thing that's it we're
done every decision I make is based
every the decision tree may go on there
may be Forks in the future but that is
unchanging
as opposed to
there's an there's a question there's an
observation there's a set of things
going on
what could explain them like a
hypothesis one which partially explains
this but doesn't explain that I got
hypothesis two which is counter to that
because it explains things differently
and they predict different things I've
got hypothesis three and you know
especially with something as complex as
covet the landscape of the last three
years it's you don't just have one set
of mutually exclusive hypotheses there's
the question of lab leak there's the
question of uh vaccine safety the
question of vaccine vaccine efficacy
of off-label treatments of all of the
various sorts that we that we have and
whether or not they're safe whether or
not effective as prophylaxis as
treatment so you know lots and lots of
different questions but for all of them
are you keeping multiple possibilities
alive in your mind at once or have you
concluded you know what this is it
nope I I will not ever ever
conclude that if it's called a vaccine
it could possibly be anything but safe
and effective for
I think that's very well said and I
would uh
just add to it that one thing that is
true is
that corrupt science will inherently be
verificationist
right that falsificationism is
incompatible it's it's almost impossible
to do it well right you might pretend to
be a falsificationist but if you look
under the hood you will find
verificationism where where science has
been corrupted
um but
let me just describe the two models and
you you will see I think why one of them
failed so badly with covet it always
fails but it failed so badly with covet
great the two models are you pick your
model of the universe or a particular
subset of the universe some discipline
how does X thing work and you apply it
as an expert but you don't question it
right and the other is you start
somewhere
and you start working towards a better
and better model by adjusting right now
my claim is going to be I don't actually
care where you start it is better to
start closer to the Target but any
process in which you actually adjust
with response to evidence will
eventually take you where you are going
and it will very rapidly surpass the
static application of anything but an
already excellent model someone
employing a self-correcting process who
is farther from the truth is someone you
would prefer to follow in their thinking
in their conclusions than someone who is
currently closer to the truth of that
matter but has is employing a static
model right now there is a degree of
difference in that if you have a very
mature understanding of some
set of facts then the model that
somebody adopts wholesale may be pretty
good to start with and so their failure
to adjust may not be a big handicap
right right but
what did we get with copen
we got a situation where nobody knew
anything right there were no good models
so the fact that X persons model was
three times as good as y person's model
had almost nothing to say about whether
it ended up better the question was are
you adjusting your model and improving
it or are you uh keeping your model
static and just applying it and so what
I'm going to claim is that all of the
people who failed so spectacularly
have not substantially changed their
opinions now there will be little cases
pointed out where people made little
adjustments by and large the people who
uh say that the vaccines are safe and
effective have not changed their tune
they in fact started with that as an
assumption and they now report it as a
conclusion
and that this is actually evident
you know it just so happens that I
Tangled with both Claire and Sam over
this issue before there was covet I
Tangled with them about the question of
whether or not vaccines are inherently
safe and my point is I I'm as I'm still
a big believer in this technology I
still think it's one of the most
marvelous success stories of traditional
vaccines and Technology vaccine
technology in principle however if
vaccines are safe it is because of a
system that prunes The Dangerous Ones
before they get to the public and we
know of multiple failures where vaccines
that were not safe got to the public and
we know of many other failures where
vaccines didn't get to the public but
failed in the testing phase and what
that tells you if vaccines are sometimes
not safe which we discover in testing
and sometimes not safe which we discover
after they've been released to the
public there's nothing inherently safe
about this technology right so if
vaccines are safe
it can only be because of an excellent
system that spots the ones that aren't
and keeps them away from you I know we
don't have an excellent system therefore
not safe right right I'm not saying any
individual vaccine is harmful but I'm
saying the idea that they are inherently
safe is uh Dead on Arrival
and so if you adopted that especially if
you had it prior to covid and then
something was pointed at you and you
they said here is a vaccine safe and
effective and you of course it's safe
and effective they all are no that's
wrong you've already demonstrated that
applying your model is Gonna Leave You
in in the gutter right
and it also
you're you're still got no no go ahead
uh it it also betrays I think the
hesitation that we saw or early in covet
if you can remember
the spring of 2020.
and what we were seeing you know at that
point we were we were just beginning our
live streams and it was
yeah there was a lot of Terror there was
you know there was confusion all of this
but overwhelmingly one of my senses was
exhilaration with regard to the
scientific literature
because the scientific literature was uh
open there was so there were so many
people at that point who as far as I
know almost no one in the very early
days was being shut down yet very
quickly that started to happen but the
pre-print servers were just were just
full of papers and there was so much
going on there was so much research
being done that the voices of authority
that decide for you which ones are good
and which ones aren't weren't doing the
work right these hadn't even made it to
journals yet so the peer review process
which is ridiculously broken wasn't in
the way the editors weren't in the way
the journalists weren't in the way what
you had if you had the you know if if
if you had the wherewithal and the
interest as we did to actually wade into
the scientific literature as it was
being generated day by day in the spring
of 2020 it's like oh my God there's so
much here and yeah we can't possibly
assess all of it but how much preferable
it is
for us and it should be for for anyone
as time consuming as it is to go to the
source and say does this make sense is
this research good as opposed to well I
don't have time for that I'm going to
trust this guy who no one had ever heard
of before who happens to run an
organization that's under the NIH who
says Nope not that this that and oh in
fauci We Trust like that quickly became
the thing that people did because they
were scared they were confused they
didn't know they wanted someone
to look at and that guy had a conclusion
a few conclusions that we now can be
pretty sure almost all of them were not
helpful for Humanity and what we were
doing and what's so you know many people
were doing but mostly not people who
were on your screens were saying we
don't know we think this let's see let's
see what is being learned and that that
ability to actually look at the
scientific literature quickly got um got
polluted of course well it did get
polluted it got captured because frankly
people were paying attention to what we
and others were making of This emerging
literature and it got in the way of
whatever I still don't have any idea
what the actual plan of those who
enforced their narrative on us was but
the point is whatever that force was
that was enforcing its narrative
whatever its motivation was it very
quickly figured out that it couldn't
very well have us discussing
um the the you know pre-pere reviewed
literature with the public oh my
goodness right that's too dangerous
[Music]